many times
what is happening at the heart of racism
are people not merely
denying other people's dignity and
humanity but denying their very own
dignity and humanity
today on chalk radio an innovative
approach to teaching about race
and racism it means you know putting
back and asking some tough questions
about our society about ourselves about
what it takes to move forward
understanding each other but also
working
to advance a much more just society and
a much better way of understanding
what it means to coexist in this episode
an urban studies course examines our
lives in public spaces
and invites us to consider how our very
personal experiences
might also contain the experiences of
others
in our conversation about his course 11s
947 the fire this time race and racism
in american cities
visiting scholar and acclaimed essayist
garnett
carrigan shares his approach for helping
students wrestle with
as he puts it the story of racism in the
united states
part of what i love about garnett's
approach is how he weaves his own life
experiences into his teaching
a large focus of his life and work has
been observing cities
through a unique modality walking
it's such a human pace
it allows us to inscribe
ourselves onto the world and allow the
world to inscribe itself
onto our imagination but more than
anything else
it's a marvelously joyful way of getting
to know the world
of getting snowed up close not merely
getting to know it but
getting to know ourselves through the
kind of
surprising encounters we might have
so one of the things i love most about
walking is the way in which it opens us
up to serendipity
so walking as a way of knowing the world
as a way of knowing ourselves as a way
of
being open to the surprise and
serendipitous of the world
garnett grew up in jamaica where he
learned to navigate public spaces
on foot in jamaica as i walked i walked
a lot at night
after public transportation had stopped
running
and would navigate from friends homes
to my home and pass through some
very dangerous neighborhoods and learned
how to
be streetwise as in
you know the wisdom gained from constant
observation
and being able to anticipate dangers
or sometimes encountering true dangers
and knowing how to get away from the
dangers and i thought that's all you
needed to do
to be in a navigating in public space
and to be safe
to anticipate the dangers and veer away
from them
when he arrived in the united states as
a college student
his experiences with racism began to
shape the way he traversed
city streets and i came to the us with
that sensibility
and then began encountering racism
but recognized that what actually
happened then it wasn't so much
learning how to read a danger but learn
to read
in places in which people thought i was
a danger that's what that happened that
and it was over and over again me seeing
the dangers and varying away from it
but then suddenly recognizing and being
shocked to know that
i was a danger and i was a danger
because i was black because of my skin
color
so navigating then suddenly became
trying to anticipate
the ways in which people would
anticipate me being dangerous
it meant calibrating my movements not to
fare
but calibrating my movements the
people's fear of me
and knowing that that could be dangerous
for me that it could mean anything from
them attacking me which had happened or
threatening to attack me
you know or them calling the police who
would then give me a tough time
i'm able to many times deal with the
awfulness
that the world throws at me because of
the beauty that the world also presents
that the world is never just
one thing and so yes their people will
shout in
awful racist things around the street
but there's also that stranger who says
oh i'm going to a barbecue and it looks
like you're just
wandering and looking for something to
do you want to come along with us
and so that's that's the very same world
the very same world there was something
so
powerful in that idea and i began to
wonder
how this outlook shaped garnett's
teaching in the classroom
how we approach the ideas of race and
racism with students with this outlook
in mind
i focus very much in the classroom in on
joy
in a way in which joy joy becomes in so
many ways
both a hope and the way it joys where to
hope but wait joy's
also read you know where to resistance
you know the way
joy is wed to our ability to
deal with these things and to push past
these things so
as a teacher i time and again
try to invite students to read the way i
walk
it becomes a way of having a
conversation in a conversation with the
past
conversation of the present a
conversation with people nearby a
conversation with people who are far
away
and more than anything is a conversation
with yourself
a way of resting with yourself that in
the end or that's my hope
in in a different self and it can emerge
a different better self much more of the
discovery and encounter
for garnett encountering others is key
to understanding the story of racism in
american cities
and for imagining a different much more
dignified way to co-exist
it's an idea that grounds how he teaches
about these complexities
what does it mean to think of the
classroom as a
place of encounter in which you're
continually
encountering these issues these
histories
these landscapes these complexities
these people
and what does it mean to truly listen to
truly understand
[Music]
garnet shared with me that it can feel
disheartening to unpack the complexities
of racism in our society
students and teachers alike may
experience burnout over the course of a
semester
as i talked with garnett it struck me
that helping students cultivate
curiosity about themselves
and others was a strategic way to
sustain their engagement
when you have something so huge it's to
say oh we're just going to climb this
mountain right away
it's it's just impossible that your legs
will give out you know quite quickly and
it will just
lead to frustration so i invite them to
just take a small
patch and to you know keep moving patch
by patch
in on that mountain until at a certain
point they look up and they go oh
we're halfway up and we're actually not
even trying to
conquer the mountain anymore this was
the wrong way to to go about it you know
we're just
now at the place in which we're happy to
investigate the terrain and then the axe
each other
what the turret looks like where you are
so i could learn more about the mountain
and
we might actually even reach the top but
we'd have a much better understanding
of landscape and of flora and fauna
and of nature and
much better sense of what it means to
hike thoughtfully
as an essayist garnett brings an
innovative slant to teaching about race
and racism
for him the act of writing and having
students write
is a way to do the work of encountering
others
writing is sometimes just merely a way
of raising questions rather than giving
answers
particularly issues connected with race
and racism and cities
that's a big order it's
a lifetime of thinking and wrestling
with complicated
issues racism race which is produced by
racism
in american cities what does it take to
understand and to wrestle
you know with the in a full inner scope
and the complications connected with
each of these
and the writing becomes a way sometimes
just mirror to ask questions to say oh
we have not been asking the right
questions this invites us to ask
new questions or this invites us to see
in
new ways this invites us to listen and
more than end things it invites us to
encounter to encounter each other in
conversation
but also encounter others on the page it
means you know pulling back and asking
some tough questions about our society
about ourselves about
what it takes to move forward
understanding each other but also
working to advance a much more just
society
and a much better way of
understanding what it means to coexist
what it means
to live together alongside each other
and the writing becomes a way to explore
that
so as they're writing they're suddenly
recognizing that the whole world
is their material and they're invited to
think
just expansively and to start
recognizing ways in which they haven't
been
seen the ways in which they haven't been
looking they're beginning to ask what
might it mean to
listen to the people who are doing harm
listen to the people who have
experienced harm and to listen you know
more fully and broadly
as my conversation with garnett
continued it became clear
that for him listening more fully
means tuning into how people navigate
the world in nuanced ways
it means writing about how they
encounter harm but also
how they cultivate joy and hope and
community
there is a temptation to write about
people who have experienced racism
as just a sum total of what has happened
to them so they're
you know merely victims with no agency
and they're then invited to go beyond
that
by suddenly asking what are the ways in
which they experience
joy what are the ways in which they hope
what are the ways in which they
work towards creating a sense of
belonging for themselves and others
what are the tight bonds of community
and
family and country
for the people that we're writing about
and what are the ways in which these are
broken or erupted or eroded
and you're not suddenly speaking of
people
in a condescending or paternalistic
matter you're speaking of people
as fully rounded you know not no longer
flattened
but you're seeing them in in rich
dimension
with aspirations and
joys and frustrations and faults
and virtues even when writing about
people as fully rounded individuals
students may encounter challenges when
learning to write about race
garnett elaborated on one of the
complexities many writers face
one of the problems with speaking about
and writing about race is that
too often people are
made to feel that their responsibilities
are to
explain one side to another side
to explain their black experience
to people who are not black
or to explain what it means to
inhabit a particular body set up
experiences
that are unique to you and
[Music]
that make moving through or living in
the world
uh much worse experience than someone
with a
different skin color but part of
the challenge is to show the ways in
which
racism degrades everyone that in
degrading someone else
you can't help but degrade yourself
and in that class one of the things i'm
trying to
invite people to do trying to invite
students to think about
is the responsibilities not merely to
think
of writing about race or understanding
race
of trying to show you know one set of
experiences to
someone who's foreign to it but to show
the ways in which
we have quite a bit of common
experiences
and that many times what is happening
at the heart of racism are people not
merely denying other people's dignity
and humanity
but deny their very own dignity and
humanity and so
it's an invitation to figure out you
know how to write about
race and racism in which we're showing
the ways in which we contain
each other so i keep giving them in a
multiple small exercises in which
time and time again they begin with
themselves and they begin by saying how
do i see
or even to write that i want to just
think about multiple voices what does it
mean
to think of writing as not just merely
speaking but as a way of integrating
your voice with the voice of others
what are other people's ways of telling
your stories and how can you
tell a story about them you know your
understanding of their story
but in a way that you know fully honors
them telling their own story
and that seems like such a huge task for
people and so i begin by saying oh let's
play critical karaoke
[Music]
garnet adopted this practice from a
music conference he attended
where attendees got to speak about a
song as the song played
i sat in on one of his classes and
observed critical karaoke in action
it was one of the most powerful teaching
methods i've seen yet
for capturing how we contain each other
they begin by starting to say this is
what the song is about or this is why
it's
relates to this particular issue or my
thinking on this issue
and you're hearing them speak about the
song but tying the song to a larger
issue that they're thinking about and
then
speaking about lyrics of the song or
something the song does
and at that point their voice phrase out
and you hear
the song the songs notes or the songs
lyrics come in and
it teaches them in a fun way you know
how to begin to think about
interweaving my voice with the voice of
others how to speak
alongside others rather than about
others in which
you're speaking about them denies them
agency
and dignity critical karaoke
is one example of how garnet is
rethinking how we engage students in
learning about racism
but there's something even more profound
at work in his teaching
he's fundamentally re-imagining a
framework
for how we approach the topic with
students viewing off a well-trod
sequential strategy and jumping into a
mind
opening matrix of connections
i'd looked at a lot of syllabuses i went
online and tried to find every syllabus
i could find that was available
at different universities about race and
racism
in america particularly in american
cities and the
approach tends to be to have it
organized by issue
this week we will discuss slavery these
weeks we will discuss slavery then
emancipation
the civil rights movement mass
incarceration
policing education environmental
injustice in housing in development
education and i found what actually
happened was that
when i began discussing by way of
issues then people in in a so often
organized around
issues and then they feel like they had
to resolve it at that moment
so he decided to shift the focus it
became
on inequality on freedom
on joy on pessimism and hope on
belonging
on mythology on unrest
on violence on resistance
on imagination it was an invitation to
say
we will not figure out mass
incarceration in one week
that it became a way of spreading the
issues
out and so mass incarceration would come
up
when we were talking about inequality
and then
it would return again when we're talking
about hope and pessimism
and then it would return again we were
talking about resistance
and they then had the invitation to
you know have spent a whole semester to
think through this thing they then
suddenly recognize the ways in which we
thought we were all bound up in each
other
the issues themselves were all bound up
in each other as you began to think
about
you know issues having to do with mass
incarceration you were also thinking
about
issues having to do with policing you
were thinking about issues having to do
with housing you were thinking about
education you were thinking about
investment and disinvestment
and suddenly instead of in a
teleological line which is so often how
we talk about race and what i recognize
with a lot of the syllabuses
it's you know and it's in a moving from
unfreedom to freedom with occasional
hiccups
that was the wrong way to think about it
rather than a matrix in which
everything was deeply connected to the
other
garnet views the act of creating his
syllabus as being
very similar to writing the narrative of
a story
one thing i do with the syllabus is that
i make the syllabus
a story in and of itself that too often
syllabuses are schematic that they're
almost
disconnected rooms in a house or they're
treated like rooms in this mansion
that there's like a site or it can go
from one to the other and i think of the
syllabus
it's like one big hall and in that in a
big hall where different gatherings
you can go and then you can come back
and so you don't leave one room and you
never return and so i
treat the syllabus like a full story and
so there are songs we will hear
and then we hear them again later on in
in a different context there are poems
that we will read and we read them again
later on
you know or there is one particular
article that they'll read on the second
week
and then we read it again on the seventh
week which seems only just when they're
like what didn't we read this again
and then they suddenly read it with new
eyes and it becomes a way of seeing
in it as a story and then i think of
things as late motifs to say
we will begin discussing this but then
we will stop
here and so they get the taste of it and
it comes back more full-blown later on
and so i think of it as a particular
narrative arc so treat the semester
itself
like a narrative arc
for garnet the syllabus must be as
multi-dimensional as the students
themselves
incorporating opportunities for joy and
reflection
and it should also be shaped by the
students voices
every week they encounter scent of
comedy and they encounter poetry
they encounter song they encounter
film they encounter short story in a
fiction
essay reportage academic article
and so there are a variety of voices and
it's an invitation
to understand the world in
many ways the world presents itself to
you knowledge
one of the fascinating things about
teaching a course like this
is you know how do you keep yourself
open to being taught
by the students in thinking about
this balancing of many voices in the
voices from the past or voices near and
far
in it can you in accommodate their
voices and
so in a class like this one has to be
very open
and you know ready to listen and to have
students express their own ultimate in
shaping it and part of
you know because there's also a great
irony not doing that because
one of the things at the heart of racism
is the denial of autonomy
to others the ways in which many times
you know
authorities used to stamp on
autonomy and for me not to listen not to
have them
be active agents in shaping and
reshaping
the class would then be a version of
that
of you know authority denying autonomy
to close i'd like to leave you with a
quote from garnett
about joy and resilience
one of the things i had made a decision
very early is that i am not the sum
total of what happens to me which is
something i in a keeper manning students
you know as they study about race and
racism that people are more than the sum
total of the awful things that have
happened to them
that there's a possibilities you know of
joy of resistance
you know of moving to the world not
ignoring the awful things that have
happened to you
but of determining that you will not let
you know these awful things
define and constrain
if you're ready to learn more about
writing and teaching about race and
racism
and unpacking the story of the american
city
you'll soon be able to find garnett
cadigan's teaching materials
on our mit open courseware website our
materials are always free
if you're an educator who remixes the
resources in your own teaching
please call or write to us to share your
story you'll help inspire others
thank you so much for listening signing
off from cambridge massachusetts
i'm sarah hansen from mit open
courseware
mom passed the car